mm breath laughs and welcome to the
walking dead it's been a long time I
missed this walking dead feeling you
know like this awesome atmosphere and
that it has the new dlc came out today
I'm so pumped to play this oh I'm not
even gonna talk more let's just [ __ ]
play yeah and I just can't move to UK
and I mean any place and you can hear
this oh wow that looks awesome
what is this can I do something yeah I
am so pumped
uh-huh oh [ __ ]
that placement the hell didn't it uh-huh
so I've been told that you can choose
between five different stories I think
or four and you can play them in
whichever order you want and the story
takes place under four hundred days
that's why it's called four hundred a
genius kid strikes again and the story
is not about Clementine orally or
anything like that it's more like a
bonus yeah yeah I think we're gonna
choose between these this is what they
tweeted on the white vine or whatever I
don't recognize any of these
these are peaceful missing yeah that guy
likes pimping even had a pee on his hand
these characters are they here they are
okay that's what is what I thought so we
got wins she'll Bonnie Russell Georgia I
feel like most people are probably
probably gonna go with Vince right away
so how about we do [ __ ] start with
Bonnie why not yeah there are five of
them so I'm going to do one each episode
pretty much there'll be five episodes
and if to get this really started if
this video gets if this video gets I
don't know nine that's too much eighty
eighty thousand likes I'll post another
one right away this is that a deal I
think that's a deal otherwise I upload
daily like I always do all right we're
gonna wait with Bonnie okay you got one
a snake for Tom you're so bad at this
would you rather have a snake for a
tongue Oh their lobster claws for ass
that's a tough one as lobster claws
that's [ __ ] bad-ass are the claws
human size lobster size or humans as
human size can make this easy on you
well I'm thinking thank Carter and how
exactly do you think harder
good point I'll think about that lobster
claws yeah go think of all the crazy
stuff you could grab
I'm saying is good luck line a man if
you haven't lobster hands good thing I'm
not looking for one then he's flirting
I hope okay how about never mind I
probably ought to stop bugging you with
stupid hypotheticals now come on
yeah you'd be a lot less fun you've been
a lot more fun lately feeling better I
guess I am
well you sure do look better you gotta
admit anything isn't improved that came
out wrong uh I mean is I mean you were
you're not perfect either you know you
know you're not perfect either mr.
lobster Haines maybe I should spend a
minute listing off your flaws like a xme
ain't perfect that's right
and you're older than dirt it's me don't
you stay off that stuff have all the
flaws you want I mean it though after we
found you you were still so hooked on
that stuff I never thought you'd make it
what's not of the woods you nuts I know
but does it make sense well you've come
a long way buddy
I'm proud of you ah oh shut up oh shut
up
what are you my sponsor I'm the best you
got god help me look you know I ain't
going nowhere right long as we're
together I'll be there for you you gotta
worry you know that right I know I know
Leland Thank You Bonnie
Leland Johnny D hey honey
son of a [ __ ] interrupted a kiss oh
that's a [ __ ] I found us something what
what are you two up to
oh we we we we we were just chatting
chatting huh
what about lobster claws when um
lobsters lobsters well fish figured it'd
be worth a shot well the food waylynn
you hate fishing
not ain't totally true and how many days
you gone fishing what I go fishing all
the time thought you didn't I am a catch
oh no I know I got you a present oh you
shouldn't have
what you fine I'll tell you later I
don't mean to interrupt your chat with
your uh girlfriend but we gotta get
moving
hey yeah I I may have tetes but I ain't
no girlfriend girlfriend so where'd you
get the baggie yeah what what's in the
bag what's in the bag D I told you it's
a surprise I don't like surprises
hey D when we get back to camp would you
let me borrow some of that nail polish
sure hon you like this color it's my
favorite and after today I could use a
new coat you know I would like some too
you're like a drowned rat with these
claws not to interrupt the Girl Talk
here but be that bad look I found it
down the road a piece all right we're
down the road someplace off that away
you just sing we've got to give us more
than that did you steal it
what yeah Bonnie's right if you stole
that bag we need to know don't got to
make no big deal out of it you guys sure
gang up on me a lot lately honey that
ain't true tell me one time you sided
with me in the last week the last month
all right can't remember one especially
but I know I have a pulse this is how
all our fights go every time now we're
standing here in the woods soaking
through and for what don't you want to
get to the camp before dark I ain't the
one who's uh what's hot huh make me some
irregardless are just as easy carry on
like this while we're walking oh I have
about had it with that attitude attitude
now with standing in this also there are
zammis in this
the drawing Bacchus for me no one
listened sir up to here with listening
are you a blast
I can't believe you are still religious
I'm humming shower baby leave leland
alone this ain't your business Barney
this is between him and me enough deep
she's right we're acting like a couple
kids that's just because you ain't
listening Bonnie darlin I'm sorry were
stylin
oh come on hey man I know what side your
bread is buttered on yours too hey I
love time ever issues we got no hash
them out later it's always later rich
honey go to hell Bonnie this is the
thanks I get after what we did for you
I'm sorry I just want to get somewhere
where I can change my clothes and then
you and your girlfriend can oh oh oh oh
God run come on we got to move
uh-uh Oh she stole the bag are we
running what about me guys
come on what kind of men good night
are you serious whoa whoa whoa
okay which way this way no that way ah
okay we're good jump whoa that's a slide
that looked a bit awkward oh oh there's
gonna be zombies Oh
whoa whoa calm down don't touch me I'm a
woman whoa that was easy
I guess high heels sighs it perks huh
why don't you just pretend to be a
zombie or something
whoa oh no not cornfields they scare me
Oh
whoa Wow Oh
that doesn't sound very good whoa this
is [ __ ] creepy okay too damn dark out
here we're up oh [ __ ]
Oh
where are you whoa that was close
oh they're everywhere uh-oh what am I
supposed to do here I guess we gotta
keep going forward okay we're going far
away we can do this breasts oh [ __ ] what
have you think no I can't see a damn
thing out here I wonder how our stories
really correlate or whatever is called
in English like it that what kind of
connection all the other five people
have four people sign uh oh oh oh oh
what is she doing she's gonna die watch
over me what about that thing honey
stay calm find a weapon a weapon that's
easy
ha hold left mouse button grab then push
the mouse left and right I was doing
that I was doing that I'm doing it it's
not working there we go oh [ __ ] this is
not working well there we go
there we go okay
I'm using Oh oh no I ain't hurt nobody
the static [ __ ] ha ha ha that's how we
do it in the purified time oh oh I'm so
sorry
oh god no I'm not what you why yeah do
do my lovin nice fatty my a the sad it's
so dark I couldn't see you I didn't know
it was you
how was I supposed to know it was you
there was no you look pretty
10 out of 10 you did this you killed me
no you're not dead you killed me nah
you're fine here's fine something a
[ __ ] never trusted you
just just chunky I'm gonna be you're
gonna be fine to me you're gonna be fine
day you're gonna be fine mmm liar
hi you did this hey I know liar him you
saw it brother I didn't Hey no no that
that [ __ ] abandoned me I need him I
need you ball it was an accident he oh I
would never I swear this has nothing to
do with him it was an accident
[ __ ] junkie oh she was a joke okay
that was right
be e did you find her
what's honey I thought they got you back
there
are you sure you saw it
what happened Oh so lowered bunk what
happen
got D
happened here
your face your face body uh I don't know
after like this how did this happen why
didn't you wait for me
isn't she going to turn
she deserves a proper burial
we came to leave her here in [ __ ] corn
for you hey hey horns are awesome yes
help me move her Bonnie please uh she
might turn what if she turns into one of
them playing Luther Leland
keep moving
wanna be closer than air
okay I don't even
I hope
ah come on now I feel like shaping to
say to her
Leland I'm here for you now sorry I
don't I don't know what to say what do
you say leave me here woody
we can't stay here forever
yeah we gotta go
what are you doing oh the backside she's
gonna die for this thing I for damn sure
ain't leaving behind what then it
I have a lot of opinions about this that
was one story
Oh No Oh No already that was so quick
but it was awesome
okay okay I'm gonna stay by my word
80,000 oh that's too much it's not too
much let's do 60 not two fifty fifty
fifty thousand likes and I'll do another
one right away
anyway I hope you bros enjoyed watching
that was very interesting
I'm so curious what the hell this is all
about you know all the stories that's
awesome
okay anyway I hope you enjoyed watching
leave a like if you did hit subscribe to
become a birthday and I'll see you in
the next one sails